in those eight years what challenges
came up oh my gosh the challenges was
you know from day one every part of this
making of I think any movies probably
especially a documentary very
challenging for this one in particular
because it was so ambitious unlike 116
row is ambitious in its own ways and it
was my first film which inherently it's
just you know ambitious to set out on
that path but with unlike 16 right that
was shot in one square mile at Van Nuys
Airport and just literally the vicinity
of a Nuys Airport this film was shot all
around the world 95 different places 18
different countries also of incontinence
and it's actually the first giant screen
film or imax film to shoot on all seven
continents and for a single one off film
so planet Earth actually has job in
seven confidence but that's episodic 10
or 11 episodes and television this is
just for 47 minutes we went all around
the world to shoot it so it was
incredibly challenging and ambitious
with logistics and the planning the
traveling everything involved getting in
and out of these countries the different
languages cultures having interpreters
and drivers and permits and just even
the equipment alone getting permission
to enter and exit countries with all
this expensive equipment always
logistical you know challenges and just
even getting permits to be where we
wanted to be alone so as months of
planning before every single shoot when
we saw you in 2009 you had finished 16
right a few years prior to that but you
were starting this but that was
different because that was sort of your
baby now you have more things on the
line how stressful was that well it's
always you know making movies is
stressful for sure I was lucky I was
making this independently similar to 16
right where I was able to create the
film sort of in a vacuum and then at the
end seek distribution with National
Geographic so they weren't involved
through the filming or the
post-production it was only at the very
end of the film so I got to make the
film I wanted to make take the time that
I wanted to take to make it the way I
envisioned it from the beginning and
then sought out distribution at the end
so it was a real luxury as a filmmaker
to have that opportunity twice now with
both of these films
so going back the beginning of the eight
years was that your plan all along to
approach someone like National
Geographic or it was Emirates also one
of the sponsors or no they just happen
to know you know Kate but they did a
grip they did a great you know thing for
one of our premieres yeah I saw it yeah
it was amazing that's why I wasn't sure
if maybe you somehow okay and I think I
saw one of the Emirates planes yep took
off right yeah um so was that your plan
did you have a list of who you were
going to approach once it was fair I had
some ideas who were going to approach
and actually did talk to National
Geographic and some others early on in
two thousand I think seven when the idea
was just hatching but I decided against
actually going with distribution from
the start just a strategic choice
because whenever you have anyone
involved whether their financing it or
going to distribute it you're basically
backing into their timeline you're
backing into their structure formula
what it might be and then you know
basically they're going to be involved
in some way maybe a little maybe a lot
and shaping what you're doing and it was
really important to me because this was
a credibly passionate idea that I had
and I wanted to see it all the way
through in the purest form possible with
a single vision that I had for telling a
story to how the airplanes changed the
world just a really tricky thesis that
you can do a thousand different ways it
was really important that that would
stay pure and the only way to do that
was in fact to be as independent as
possible and to have a hundred percent
creative control and it's very difficult
if not impossible to do that with
somebody involved anybody involved from
the beginning in terms of distribution
because you need to hit the mark that
they want you to hit or the mark that
you've agreed to hit and you don't have
the flexibility inherently to go longer
to make changes to have the story
evolved potentially become may be much
better much greater but it's different
you're telling it different structurally
than at one point in time on paper and
it's very difficult to be able to allow
to be allowed to do that if you have
distribution in place from day one so
it's a risk for everybody to do this as
basically a spec project but I've done
it twice now and I will always worked
out Wow Brian I just have to ask because
even though eight years I'm sure you
lost a lot of sleep and it was
frustrating at times it sounds
really cool and I'm I'm pretty envious
so how are you able to forgive me for
being so nosy about how are you able to
do this over eight years yeah so I
learned from one sixth right how
important it is in the beginning to make
sure to raise enough money that's going
to see through all the way to the very
ends so because this film was so
ambitious and I knew that we were going
to have an a-list narrator in an a-list
composer and shoot all around the world
and shoot with the best camera we get
our hands on and it was just gonna be an
expensive film that it was really
important to be able to have all the
money not enough money to get started or
enough money to get halfway through or
enough money to just get through
production because I've seen that happen
many many times and then you never get
to finish the film that you started or
you find yourself in all sorts of
situations where you're compromising
cutting corners this sort of thing and
that's just not in my DNA it was really
important that this realizes the full
vision of what I had first thought of
you know in an end product the only way
to do that is to be able to start only
when you have all the money secure it
and so I took a long time I took the
better part of a couple years to be able
to get that and then when we finally did
it was 2010 8 2009 / 2010 we were
finally in that position and that's when
production got underway